[Musik]
hallo welt ist ein rezept von mir als
drei mal in der woche
und wahr mache ich heute eine chance
damit ist es nicht beim ihrer freundin
charlotte gemeint sondern dieses gutes
stück hier
das ist eine torte und die rente
charlotte habe ich nämlich eine
biskuitrolle gemacht die zurecht
geschnitten ohne richtig toller schüssel
damit ausgekleidet und innen drin steckt
dann erfüllung
das ganze habe ich es als eistorte flug
bereitet aber ihr müsst es auch nicht
einfrieren sondern könnt auch
kühlschrank kalt essen als finde ich
genial vor allem bei dem warmen wetter
jetzt draußen und chemie dann habe ich
eine joghurt mascarpone eis und
erstellung und ist wirklich super lecker
vor allem können wir jetzt gerade die
kiste so ausnutzen und das alles
zubereiten editors bereit
aber das liegt ja auch mit drin und ich
zeige euch jetzt mal erst die zutaten
für die biskuitrolle die muss man zuerst
herstellen und ansonsten muss ich sagen
die sie kompliziert aus aber ist
wirklich super einfach vor allem ist
schnell gemacht man kann sich
vorbereiten und einfacher im
gefrierschrank lagern
ich zeige euch hier nochmal die zutaten
für die kontrolle für den respekt
brauche ich die eier wie es löffel
heißes wasser eine prise salz etwas
bunny lake packt 120 gramm zucker den
abrieb einer unbehandelten zitrone 65
vom stärke 75 gramm mehl und zwei
teelöffel backpulver wenn ich zuerst
einmal die eier die balten auf jeden
fall immer warm sein so lassen sie sich
besser aufschlagen
arbeitet man auch das wasser hier ist
damit einfach ein bisschen schneller
geht dann noch die prise zucker
und natürlich ein bisschen weg fragt wer
fleißig die masse in etwa drei bis vier
minuten dick cremig aufschlagen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die ava schön dick prämie
bringen könnte jetzt habe ich auch schon
die zitronenschale abgegeben
deswegen ist ganz wichtig dass es eine
unbehandelte zitrone ist damit eben
nicht gespritzt mit rein und dann werden
wir trockenen zutaten vermischt und
gesät info entstehen dann einfach keine
klümpchen
[Musik]
die hebe ich jetzt ganz vorsichtig mit
einem schneebesen unter natürlich den
teig in einem vorbereiteten back haben
den hab ich auf meinen wachstum auch
eine sauerbach folie gesetzt und der
wird jetzt hier schön verteilt
[Musik]
ihr seht ist auch dass die masse
wirklich richtig schön luftig und auch
sehr stabil ist und normalerweise wird
bei fitmacher auch kein backpulver
verwendet ich sage nur dass du nimmst
trotzdem vor allem wenn ihr zum beispiel
nicht mit einer küchenmaschine arbeitet
weil es einfach ganz ganz wichtig ist
bei der betritt masse wirklich die worte
sehr lange gerührt wird dann braucht ihr
keine backpulver aber minuten und
handrührgerät habt und nicht von
anrührender später klappte baku sorgte
am besten jetzt unter zeigt so in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze und wird für etwa 80 minuten
gebacken
wir nehmen den damen raus wenn das
fertig ist es sollte auf keinen fall
werden und auch nicht trocken werden
damit die pistole später eben auch nicht
kritisiert
jetzt kommt die biscuits platte ganz aus
dem ofen und ich kann will von der
backform lösen
dafür nehme ich jetzt mein bart vom
messer und löse den bug rahmen dann lege
ich das geschirrtuch drauf und dann kann
ich mit hilfe eines partners die platte
stürzen ist nur noch die power pack
folie weg und dann kann ich das ganze
mit hilfe des geschäfts auf rollen und
so las ich die betrieb platte ist
einfach abfilmen und kann in der
zwischenzeit die führung vorbereitet für
die kirsch bildung brauche 500 gramm in
steinkirchen dann nehmen wir entweder
frische oder gefrorene eine unbehandelte
zitrone 8 bis zum futter und für die
joghurt füllung frau 100 milliliter
schlagsahne 250 gramm joghurt soll
nämlich ist eine zehnprozentigen etwas
man electric 250 gramm macht abholen und
150 computer bekommen so einfach man
nehme ich jetzt wie kirschen und jacke
zwar auf die tiefe fordern
zurückgegriffen wenn sie sind auch
bereits von entstand und dann könnt ihr
auch die torte auch mal außerhalb dafür
sorgt zu bereiten weil die früchte immer
richtig reif geerntet werden und dann
einfach tiefgefroren werden
[Applaus]
ich kann deine bourne wieder auftauen
lassen oder es einfach gleich im topf
machen
da gebe ich jetzt zucker dazu und dann
nimm dir einfach super nach bedarf auch
wenn die kirchen zum film könnt ihr auch
ein bisschen weniger nehmen wenn sie
seien sauer sind nehmen wir einfach ein
bisschen mehr
da kommt noch der abrieb der zitrone
dass du und auch gleich zitronensaft
eine klasse die füllung aufkochen und
dabei mittlerer hitze einkochen bis eine
schöne dicke konsistenz entstanden ist
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier schon mal die kripo
bereiten dafür habe ich jetzt diese hier
in die schlüssel oder keine cesana schon
mal ein bisschen steif schlagen und ich
nehme jetzt hier auch keinen seiner
fahrt weil ich erst spät hat die torte
sowieso 1 werden werde und später eine
eistorte wird einfach gott führen
und hier schonmal vanille extrakt und
das gefühl hören
[Musik]
hätte es die sahne fast ganz steil aber
ich lasse jetzt erstmal so jetzt gebe
ich noch joghurt und mascarpone dazu und
da nehme ich gern den zehn prozent weil
er einfach besonders cremig ist ihr
könnt natürlich auch einen 35
prozentigen nehmen aber zum schmeckt das
ganze ein bisschen besser mit dem wind
ist wirklich richtig schön krems 8w
frozen yogurt
[Musik]
robot game habe ich jetzt schon in den
kühlschrank gestellt und während sie
noch die herstellung ein bisschen
einkauf kann ich mich umgekehrt rolle
kümmern
die sind nämlich schon abgekühlt und die
rolle ich jetzt gerne vor wichtig auch
noch lauwarm
aber das ist gar nicht schlimm weiß
sowieso nur eine marmeladen füllung 1
kommt und da nehme ich jetzt einmal eine
badische schwarz kirche passte perfekt
zum partnerin dem urlaub zur begeistert
sein als schwabe aber angenehm streiche
ich jetzt schön mit einer palette oder
mit einem messer
[Musik]
erstes auffallen
wir wollen jetzt auch die wirklich jetzt
ein und lass dir einfach ein bisschen
stehen die herstellung wirklich
schönblick flüchtete also könnt ihr auch
mal so kontrollieren damit das machen
und witz und viel flüssigkeit sind
natürlich auch daher dass ich tief
gefrorener kirchen genommen habe wenn
ihr frische kirschen nehmt ihr das ganze
ein bisschen schneller und so bald
wirklichkeit ist noch weiter verdunkelt
ist wenn es im herausstellen die kühlung
abkühlen lassen und dann können wir
dieses gefühl die eiskugeln einfach
schön hersteller jetzt alles abkühlen
jetzt ganz die biskuitrolle
zurechtschneiden da werde ich jetzt etwa
sechs sendet achten teile schneiden und
das ganze einfach mitfahren messer
jetzt habt ihr diese discrete schmecken
die schnecken so schon richtig lecker
aber später in kombination mit füllungen
oder cremig was ich noch mal für lecker
fand ich ja eine große runde schüsse das
ist ein richtig schöner von rippchen
halbkugel dem ich jetzt mit etwas
frischhaltefolie ausgelegt und kann
jetzt ihr die teile reinlegen
und am besten immer mit der schönen
seite nach unten die erste rolle direkt
in die mitte und in die schüssel fahrten
etwa dreieinhalb liter flüssigkeit rein
so können wir in etwa abschätzen wie
gross
b
[Musik]
das ist hier die grundlage und jetzt
kommt für die füllung rein und das ganze
mit marmoriert gefeiert kommt immer ein
löffel von der weißen krähen dann an
diesen kirsch füllung und das ganze
immer abwechselnd
[Musik]
das ganze ein bisschen vorsichtig klappt
streifen und jetzt denke ich die kugel
ab und dann kommt sie in den
gefrierschrank für mindestens 4 stunden
und danach gibt gut berichtet weil ich
sie fertig stellen und fahre ich jetzt
was wir noch einen notweg boden machen
beweist butter und texte vermischen
ihr wisst ihr schon mal 125 glauben
butter in einem topf verlassen und
harrten noch 15 frauen sich konkret sind
das volk genommen und an den mixer fein
zerkleinert die mission jetzt bin ich
die mischung ganz kurz in den
glasbehälter um damit ziemlich nur angst
und dann kommt es direkt auf die torte
drauf ihr könnt den teil auch weglassen
aber ihr müsst euch vorstellen wie
kuppel torta betonten die cd skript
böden und wände stützte hat ja gar
keinen boden mehr unter
wenn euch im staat könnte zu lassen ihr
könnt auch lassen bild wird einfach
drauf machen
egal was ihr möchtet ich hab mich jetzt
für den größen boden hier entschieden
weil er später einfach schön gemacht
[Musik]
ist alles schön glatt streichen am
besten auf eine ebene zeigt auch
tortenböden und bisschen runter drücken
er musste noch mal kurz durchführen eine
halbe stunde oder stunde
ihr könnt es auch über nacht ist einfach
abgedeckt ins gefrierfach geben und dann
kümmert sich verlieren die torte wird
gut durch gekühlt und ich hab die paten
platte gestört aber im wahrsten sinne
wort ist wie es mehr strom vergiftet und
erreichte auf der zweiten platte gesetzt
aber jetzt sehe ich nichts passiert das
ist in der bomben feste torte allein
franck und ich werde jetzt anschneiden
und der moral ist leider noch nicht nach
dann vom globus hat noch paar wochen
vergessen ich nochmal kaufen
das heißt leider die torte probieren
beziehungsweise meint ihn kriegt einfach
lecker oder jeder nochmal abgaben
untertassen ein gemeinschaftsprojekt
martin ist ja auch ganz cool die torte
wird ziemlich schnell wieder warm bei
uns hat wird er auch 30 gerade in der
küche
deswegen trägt jetzt gleich noch mal ein
und man sollte sie auch sofort essen
wenn sie nämlich die form ist und ich
habe jetzt nur vier stunden kühlen
lassen dann ist er noch nicht komplett
durchgefroren wenn ihr jetzt aber über
nach dem gefrierschrank habt dann mich
willst du nicht so schnell hat sich hier
schon die füllung und ganz so schmeckt
wie amarena kennt ihr wahrscheinlich vom
laden und es schmeckt auch die amarena
eis zum einladen
sehr lecker vor allem finde ich dass die
biskuitrolle außenrum sehr saftig ist
mit der kirsch füllung weiter auf
badisch ins badische eine badische
schokolade war schlechte rolle
wahrscheinlich extrem lecker
falls ihr das rezept nach machen wollt
könnt ihr auf meinem blog gehen auch
wenn das blog de dass sie jetzt noch mal
ganz genau mein team da willkommen wir
probleme mit orten wie hier trägt sofort
wieder ein weil sie nicht am start vom
schmerz und ich kein foto machen kann
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
machen und bekommt alle zusammen ob
jetzt die badische zerstörte
[Musik]
rheine
ich lasse
drei bis vier minuten die cremig
aufschlagen
jetzt war scheint
[Musik]